[Music]
hi rob this is christy from spokane
washington big fan parks and rec is my
favorite show
i read both of your books during the
pandemic and i just love your stories
your humor and
just how self-deprecating you are
really enjoy the podcast and you as a
person
so my question is are we ever going to
see you do a comedy stand-up tour
i feel like you did at one point i could
be mistaken but i would love to see you
on the road at a city near me
to maybe
share more of your stories that
sometimes seem
so critical to be true that they are
and yeah so that's my question keep up
the good work and i love everything you
do thank you
oh thank you i love everything about you
and i don't even know you
um that's very nice lots of good
compliments in there
um and i can never have enough of those
uh
so
yeah you you kind of intuited
what my one man show
stories i only tell my friends live
is if i had the balls i would just say
it's
stand-up because it's stories for sure
but
i think people come away from it going
that was funny it's like a lot of laughs
in in with kovid
um that put a halt to it
but i was doing there was a
there was about two years there where i
was probably doing two shows two or
three shows a month
in in while i was also shooting my tv
projects
and that's starting to come back as all
things are but i'm i'm so busy i'm doing
911 lone star the two podcasts and my
new netflix show
so that's how
in between the travel that that part has
taken the backseat but i'm going to
revive it when i can for sure and
hopefully i will bring it to
a town near you because i love it i love
being on stage and
being with people and just relating and
it's exactly what you think it's going
to be so i'm excited for you to come and
hopefully i'll see you soon
you